hey what's up guys look around me it's
amazing
several months ago I was on a walk and
found my crib tree I approached the tree
murdered it left it to cure in my
woodshop and have begun working it into
a crib for my upcoming child run Swanson
you cannot use this crib you're ignoring
every known crib safety standards it's
all covered in the parenting book I'm
reading are you going to crawl my way by
Lenny Kravitz my crib will be safe
because I'm building it with my own two
hands I bought my crib in Bloomington
and I am confident that it is literally
with you save his crib in the explored
universe let me take you there and you
could talk to the salesperson
counteroffer
you take me nowhere and I talk to no one
counter counteroffer you come with me or
I make you attend a four-hour fax cover
sheet protocol meeting either way is a
win for me and found this place it's
where we bought our sounds nature
machine you bought a machine that
replicates an open window Frazier Chris
Traeger do you remember me I came in
here looking for the Vanna White book on
child care I'd like to solve the puzzle
of parenting could you show my friend
Ron that amazing crib that you sold me
the baby love a little sweetheart
safe forever and ever model oh yeah that
think has a death trap I'm sorry just
found out this morning it's being
recalled
they found maxi silo fen to ball in the
glue is that good it sounds bad it
burned off my fingernails I'll be in the
car Ron I want to do things the Swanson
way wonderful first rule no conversation
last longer than 100 total words you
have used nine I have used 20 continue
fun I'd like you to teach me to build a
crib
why do you need to build your own crib
because I no longer trust anything other
than my own two hands thank you for the
woodworking lesson run this whole crib
recall things got me literally
rethinking everything I thought I knew
about parenting what's the method will
you be using Ferber Sears Swanson method
where you close your eyes and fall
asleep
I really wish Ron would engage but he
exudes so much wisdom that I can learn
parenting tips simply by being in his
presence someone like Ron is teaching
even when they're not teaching does that
make sense my anxiety has kept me up for
over 50 hours
if a joint is properly fashioned all you
need to do is guide it into place all
you need to do is guide it into place
what I get from that is when parenting
sometimes a subtle hand is more
effective than a strong one this is
already so much more helpful than the
last book in parenting I read rad dads
by Apolo Anton Ohno and Shaun White Ron
why did you throw that wood away it's
unstable it's no good I just don't
understand the throwing away the wood
metaphor what's the lesson oh I know
it's potty training that trash can is
the toilet and the wood was the feces
Chris I'm not teaching you anything
we're just building a crib no I know
you're not consciously teaching me
anything I'm just trying to siphon off
some of your calm centered wisdom
through metaphors metaphors
I hate metaphors that's why my favorite
book is Moby Dick
no frou-frou symbolism just a good
simple tale about a man who hates an
animal that's enough for today I think
an organized child musing rot what's
this the crib I built I'm giving it to
you and Ann it's perfectly safe I tested
it by hitting it with my truck well Ron
I can't accept this is for your baby
there's more than one crib tree in a
forest that's not a lesson by the way
just a comment on lumber availability
it's beautiful thank you nobody has all
the right answers in parenting including
me and that toxic crib you bought won't
be the last mistake you make but a man
who is this worried about making all the
right choices cares very much that's all
that matters you'll be a great father
thank you Ron for the crib and the
advice it's much better than any
metaphor does the white whale actually
symbolize the unknowability and
meaninglessness of human existence
that's just
you